bien alors annie girardot bonsoir très
heureux de vous voir alors vous dites
page 210 de votre livre que le que de
cinéma vous a parfois oublié mais pas
les spectateurs vous dites je fais
partie de la famille je suis dans le
coeur des français et c'est vrai
c'est publié au cherche midi ça
s'appelle partir revenir les passions
vives et ça raconte votre vie annie
girardot
alors quand on lis ce bouquin qui
raconte votre vie on voit bien que cette
espèce de tristesse cette fêlure que
vous avez dans votre personnalité
remonte à l'enfance avec la mort de
votre père et surtout la la séparation
obligé d'avec votre mère qui était trop
pauvre pour vous garder auprès d'elle
votre frère et vous voilà alors après
vous racontez votre arrivée à paris
votre mère qui vous inscrire aux cours
d'art dramatique de la rue blanche le
conservatoire dont vous sortez avec un
premier prix de comédie classique et
moderne
votre entrée à la comédie française
votre éviction de la comédie française
parce que comme beaucoup à l'époque j'ai
voulu faire du cinéma et c'était pas
n'étaient pas compatibles
votre rencontre avec cocteau pour la
machine à écrire à l'odéon avec robert
hirsch votre rencontre avec visconti
pour deux sur la balançoire on théâtre
avec jean marais et là vous êtes choisis
par visconti pour le film rocco et ses
frères avec alain delon renato salvatori
renato salvatori qui est on peut le dire
je crois annie girardot l'homme de votre
vie il ya pas de la giulia bien sûr et
vous dites
la première fois que vous le voyez j'ai
failli m'évanouir
a été beau a été beau un écran un thème
bien les sommes qui seront grands
c'est le grand amour d'annie girardot
d'ailleurs vous coucher avec lui dès le
deuxième soir
les vieilles fiche vous avez des
économies j'avais des manies comme ça
évidemment pas le premier soir c'est ce
que je voulais dire genre vous avez
connu une soirée je trouve ça très bien
que j'étais folle de lui
c'est dans le bouquin
de jour
même trois on vous dit qu'un miroir
d'eau dès la première seconde il m'a
marqué au fer rouge de la passion renato
c'est mon homme mon corps l'a compris
avant moi
fermez les guillemets fermez les
guillemets c'est vous dit si c'était un
animal sauvage une panthère ben c'est le
terrain c'est le grand amour 1 s'est dit
quelqu'un qui doit être très violent un
très violent et pour tout le monde d'un
seul coup il était très gentil à doha
mais s'il casse couilles avec quelqu'un
qui faisait quelque chose me rappelle du
tout foncer dessus tout on partait
concocté sur la route comme ça je ne
sais plus dont on allait de forte
démarre mais je ne sais plus quoi et un
moment il y avait à ce moment là mais
est il dépassé un camion évidemment il
arrivait juste au truc qu'on va
s'arrêter fait le machin le péage comme
ça y'a un acquis harry se trouvera dès
qu'une espèce de truc pour mettre harper
s'est jeté sur la toile et vous avez
peur on a eu peur à temps mais ils sont
comme les passagers alors ce qui était
jusqu'à ce mois ci à massy d'une camion
est possible de la paix vous êtes barré
quoi
heureusement parce que je dois quand
même joué hier on était par exemple
vous décidez de vous essayez de vous
marier avec renato salvatori vous êtes
enceinte vous de giulia donc est en fait
le seul enfant vous ayez jamais c'était
la réduit à la nuit de noces vous êtes
pratiquement obligé de le violer parce
qu'il n'était pas très fan à des femmes
enceintes qui était très bien
et donc ensuite c'est vrai qu'après le
mariage vous ne voyez plus pendant cette
semaine il est parti jouer au poker à
cortina d'ampezzo avec ses copains
belle cote qu'elle connaissait pas les
hommes et l'italien ah bon à mon séjour
de coureurs bien sûr ni son label faut
aussi faire un bon il faut aussi cesser
ces actes à vis de quoi couvrir le jury
n'allait pas qu il ya les jouets way we
are elle moi j'aimerais forte dès mardi
et elle aime jouer au poker il ya liège
et je sais que je vais souvent je
restais avec lui comme ça je regardais
et puis à un moment je vais me coucher
je ne pouvais plus il reste jusqu'à midi
un moment alors pas pu les secousses et
alors il faisait tout alors qu'il
appelle la péniche est là comme on dit
et alors à tout ça m'a presque par sd
tout beau pour aller vers eux jouer aux
cartes et tout ça il était comme ça m'a
beaucoup de séparation parce que vos
métiers vous sépare vous êtes souvent à
paris et lui avant c'est-à-dire quand
j'avais à travailler à paris oui mais il
m'est arrivé d'être à rome prenez
beaucoup l'avion quoi je parle t il prêt
à la vie on peut s'enlever toute façon
j'étais à prêt permanent quelquefois
j'aide à rome pour le pape répond
repartir le lendemain parce que vous
savez rome c'est bien gentil quand il
est paul tu as des cloches sa lentille
t'emmerde non yakov déclenché des vagues
ligne dangdang a confié le major
la
bbc battait alors moi je rentre à paris
c'est vrai que la dolce vita la via
veneto c'était pas si bien que ça
finalement ça n'existe pas ouais c'est
monsieur fellini c'est son talent voilà
donc avec renato salvatori histoire
durera quand même 15 ans ouais et on
apprend en lisant ce bouquin d'autres
aventures que je ne soupçonnais pas dit
gérard doz jacques brel vous dites ces
mots ont marqué ma vie avant qu'il
marque que mon corps je sais pas ce que
c'est mais en tout cas c'est cet homme
pourquoi il était abonné c'est comme ça
et où il le disait et tout mais il avait
un charme tout gelé connu vraiment c'est
en tournant c'était
la bande à bonnot abordable de la bande
à bonnot vous dit en parlant de l'enbrel
ses mains tremblantes son visage creusé
par l'émotion ses lèvres mouillé il
était beau et je le désirais déjà mais
bref je vous sous france quelque chose
là bas âge ont fait pas qu'il y avait
quelque chose qui m'a crochet il vous
plaisait pas ce que vous dites il
éveille en moi un désir physique que je
n'ose me vouer dire qu'en fait c'est à
dire que oui parce que tu le vois mais
tu tournes a vécu c'est pas qu'une idée
de chercher là ça s'est fait comme ça et
puis ça n'est pas se faire puis ça s'est
fait ben ça c'est très bien ça c'est
fait difficilement parce que un an après
le film la bande à bono il vient vous
voir place des vosges en appartement
vous aviez à l'époque il se passe pas
grand chose un petit flirt faire des
choses comme ça très et il n'était pas
libre en fête c'est quelqu'un de très
honnête qui voulait pas et n'est tête
avec une femme et à ce moment là et m'a
dit je n'ai pas été de voir là où tu te
remets parce que je suis avec une femme
jeune ou bon je les ai très bien compris
vous vous dites en parlant de braine
j'ai qu'un regret un grand regret on
sait jamais dit je t'aime
c'est vrai alors il ya une autre
aventure qu'on apprend aussi en lisant
vos trucs assez lellouche savait pas moi
claude lelouch à bout ouais c'est vrai
la caméra bouge tout le temps on n'a pas
vu
alors votre histoire avec le votre
histoire avec lelouch été découverte par
un paparazzi dans un hôtel en normandie
lellouche a cassé la gueule paparazzi et
vous alors ce qui est extraordinaire
c'est créé nato salvatori à ce moment là
il vous fait une scène
c'était s'était saisi du véritable vous
dire ce n'était pas dieu à l'homme
apprend on apprend aussi votre amour
platonique avec louis de funès c'est
beaucoup plus étonnant alors oui c'est
une meyrin l'histoire d'amour très pur
vous dites un bain c'est un homme qui va
durer je l'adoré aussi on s'en est pas
rendu compte ouais non c'est parce que
on a fait un film on s'en est pas rendu
compte du tout
zizanie et un jour je sais plus madame
de funès a réclamé aux producteurs en
disant qu'il fallait lui donner une
soupe de gerbes de fleurs parce que on
avait il avait trahi
c'était un homme comme ça avec moi je
mets les folles les 10 juillet dire ça
je vais pas dire cette femme enfin elle
a su que j'avais trahir ses deux fils
est comme ça que rien ferait mieux fini
ce n'est rien du tout alors rien de rien
du tout alors je la rassure c'est un
rien passé du tout seulement cet homme
quand tu voyais de finesse la
gentillesse qu'il avait et avait un
amour on avait un amour comme si j'avais
beaucoup douceur dans le regard vif et
quelqu'un je sais qu'il me met et sa
belle je l'aimais un livre vous racontez
vous raconter aussi dans les zones de
votre vie bob decout l'échec du
spectacle au casino de paris en mina et
au vert le camion disant sauver notre
part et comme
monsieur monsieur monsieur l'homme
despatie disait oui très bien puisque
nice est toujours tout oui je sais je
sais gg j'ai conservé la façade non
seulement la façade monsieur liste tous
kayumba toutes les blagues et son
l'escalier et sont les skates merci
j'en ai marre non c'est vrai mais enfin
on peut dire amis on peut dire que vous
avez sauvé le casio taille compacte et
valéo et renault qui devait devenir
intitulé terre et et du cac n'était pas
au casino barrière vous avez sauvé vous
avez sauvé le casino de paris qu'il y
était si je l'aimé quand j'allais la
voir
je vous remercie et elle était et est tu
peux tu peux pas pas d une non non non
les rangs du leu leu leu vraiment le
casino de paris on hamm est rien a pas
marre on n'a rien eu prêt à tout on
s'est fait voler si tous ces bons soirs
c'était se situe quoi les syndicats j'en
sais rien je ne sais pas tout ce que je
peux vous dire
ce n'est pas tout vous hurlez payé très
cher alors que la dernière fait on a au
nom on n'a pas eu d'argent on n'a rien
eu du tout ça moi je me suis sauvé la
vie
c'est vrai je dis que monsieur je dis
que
j'ai dit que bobino n'a pas eu assez de
chance
vous pourrez
donc vous raconter cette histoire du du
casino de paris mais quand même oui vous
dites ça vous a coûté très cher c'est
vrai que vous êtes est obligé de vendre
votre appartement place des vosges gros
du tout
des soucis dans le bouquin
oui mais bon ça va ensuite annie donc
traversée du désert et ses lellouche qui
vous permet un retour en force au cinéma
en 96 c'est pas vrai chameau partie
nous avons des expressions que
j'entendais pi3k lelouch devaient pas
permis un retour en force en 96 avec les
misérables pour laquelle vous avez eu
d'abord que lelouch il m'a apporté tout
quand j'ai fait d'abord vivre pour vivre
ouais je pense que il m'a fait c'étaient
nos ménages qui m'a fait faire savait
pas tourné je n'avais pas un mec qui me
disait c'est comme ça je ne savais pas
d'un seul coup tu as l'histoire de bons
temps qui te dit d'être ce que coûte
mais dans une réalité tu as ce combat je
me marre j'ai un mec comme ça qui est
pas toujours cinq ans tu comprenais le
prof au quartier s'ils partent alors tu
vas nous dira un montant entre tours et
dire que
est-ce que
donc donc lellouche vous a quand même
permis en 96 avec les misérables de de
revenir et d'avoir un césar du second
rôle féminin
balshaw l'importance vient alors donc ça
c'était les césar et puis ensuite il ya
à cannes en 2000 présentation de la
pianiste de michael haneke grand prix du
jury est là c'est terrible ce qui vous
ont fait parce que vous avez préparé
votre petite robe noire de ces versace
avec laquelle vous aviez films émissions
de télévision d'ailleurs hommage à brel
et la séquence avait été coupée et un
petit peu comme si cette robe vous
porter malheur vous n'êtes pas invités à
cannes par l'équipe du film
c'est dans le bouquin
bah oui mais c'est la crise en bref je
veux dire je raconte des choses parce
qu'il ya un moment où je suis fatigué
ouais
j'allais tourner avec philippe de broca
et jean pierre marielle la non une taxe
extraordinaire ça ça s'appelle je sais
pas encore vous savez que je disais
président de broca je le rencontre il
était à la brute il apporte dire que tu
pourrais pas tourner encore avec moi
rémois on est vieux d'accord mais on
pourrait le faire quand même des buts un
total mais ce n'est pas de sujets ont
alors trouvé un sujet est totale il a
quand même retenu la leçon alors il
paraît que mais c'est plus avec loiret
si l exemple a remarqué jean vient de
marianne louis que vous avez initié au
nudisme l'île du levant c'est à dire
qu'il est arrivé lui la suisse retient
est sorti tout seul à quatre
j'ai habité il est venu il est venu avec
son petit bateau je me rappelle vous
voyez qu'on lui a volé d'ailleurs dans
le train il a perdu il avait trop
différent de celui ci est envoyé dans le
train vous voyez vous dites moi vous
aviez vous aviez l'île du levant avec
votre maman depuis très longtemps
rabat 20 ont écouté heureux l'été c'est
une maman suzuki- était un la guerre
alors évidemment maman 6 ou évidemment
on va aller à l'aigu levant un euro
valait du levant la première fois on n'y
va pas on racle arabella tôt pour
retenir donc on a couché dans les
grottes et tupina secondes et c'est très
bien que finalement on est resté
et puis avec moment les est très
heureuse voilà et donc là vous avez
invité à l'époque tous vos amis dont
jean-pierre mariam c'est l'homme qui me
fait le plus rire manger peu le film
abouti mais alors me
et celui là tu retournes et avec lui
c'est quelqu'un qui est d'une drôlerie
et mme alors c'est vraiment mon maître
tout va bien au cinéma tu vois hein
parce qu'on se répondent comme ça que
c'est extraordinaire c'est sur l'île du
levant vous avez perdu votre virginité
aussi annie girardot
l'enquêté
parce qu'avais il y avait eu une
tentative sur le couvre-lit de votre
mère qui avait pas marché oui et en fait
non j'en avais eu il y avait quelqu'un
ou c'était ça va pas marcher un épi là
comme à ben ali lui vends ma foi ses
ennemis avec un père s'il y avait des
scorpions j'avais peur et misère et puis
ça s'est passé très peu d'achats j'étais
très contente c'est après tout ça vous
ne serez pas étonnés joueurs donc je
vous fasse une interview à penda
[Musique]
un milliard de ce que vous préférez en
vous et ben que c'est chez personne
que j'ai un toit qui va pas dans la
range et toi dirait que tu me fais chier
alors eh ben les breuilletois qui sait
tout et puis et puis c'est sale je veux
dire ce que vous détestez en vous
écoutez je suis pas ma vie pas me
changer en mieux je pourrais dire fils
[ __ ] jamais été une salle 1 une belle
[ __ ] qui fait cocu les
mets ça qu'il ne fait pas ce que vous
préférez dans le cinéma le cinéma bonnes
réponses que vous détestez dans le
cinéma donnée plus fier de cinéma si
malheureuse 1
mais j'adore le théâtre
mais le cinéma pour moi c'est devenu
évident je pense qu'il était beau cinéma
autant au théâtre
diack à jouer à mario ici une chose
mais au cinéma
tu peux te donner
tu peux dans les émotions tu vas dans
les choses que tu as donné tu polito né
peut les donner aux russes d'abord tu
m'as donné pourquoi des gens écrivent
pourquoi ils me disent pourquoi parce
que les ai touché sur quelque chose
c'est à dire que comme ça tu vas langage
et tous comprennent ils te comprennent
et écrivent le plus grand moment de
votre vie
alors maintenant
les bons la naissance
de grands moments qu'est ce que c'est
des moments c'est des moments de d'amour
oui bah je parle d'abord ma fille de
d'avant le bonheur d'avoir eu cette mère
que j'ai eu mon frère a mis le plus au
moment de votre vue le débarquement ah
ouais ouais ouais
parce que j'ai peur de ce jour là ce que
vous préférez dans la vie
j'aime bien rigoler ouais
j'en ai dit mais je fume un j'aurais
jamais rien parce que j'ai dit que je
l'aurais pas rien et puis c'est tout
faux pas interdit d ce que vous détestez
dans la vie les gens qui font grincheux
et six mois
votre plus belle nuit avec un homme a
oui c'était pas forcément des nuits mais
on n'attend même pas
les gens qui arrivent et qui parque
drame et après est votre pire nuit avec
un homme
c'est pas possible
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
inhabituel abonnez vous y mettez un peu
de bleu